the head of the Senate Judiciary
Committee wants to hear from former FBI
deputy director Andrew McCabe in person
this weekend McCabe will tell television
viewers how the Special Counsel
investigation into alleged Russian
collusion began and his efforts to
actually try to remove President Trump
from office chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge has
specifics tonight you're having a
conversation about whether or not you're
gonna invoke the 25th amendment the
Republican Senate Judiciary Committee
Chairman did not rule out a subpoena to
compel testimony from Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein and former Deputy
FBI director Andrew McCabe about
discussions to remove President Trump I
would imagine if the shoe were on the
other foot my Democratic colleagues have
worn a no about that conversation if it
involved with Democrat Graham was
responding to McCabe's upcoming 60
minutes interview according to CBS
McCabe confirmed long-standing media
reports including by Fox that he
believed Rosen's time was serious about
wearing a wire to record the president I
was speaking to the man who had just run
for the presidency and and won the
election for the presidency and who
might have done so with the aid of the
government of Russia
May 17 is a pivotal month Rosen Stein
was just two weeks into the job when FBI
director James Comey was fired by the
president in response and obstruction of
justice investigation was opened in
addition to the FBI's ongoing Russia
collusion probe I wanted to make sure
that our case was on solid ground in a
statement the Justice Department seemed
to stop short of denying Rosenstein
talked about removing the president
quote the Deputy Attorney General never
authorized any recording that mr. mchabe
references based on his personal
dealings with the president there was no
basis to invoke the 25th amendment in a
tweet President Trump hit back
characterizing McCabe as quote disgraced
and a puppet for leaking James Comey
with the special counsel appointment
McKay's role was significantly reduced
and last spring he was fired for
violating the FBI's code of ethics for
lying
McCabe's cases now with the US Attorney
here in Washington for possible criminal
prosecution Brett Catherine thank you